[Music]
hi
i'm councillor bex and i'm here to talk
to you about invercargill city council's
representation review
the community panel is set up by the
invercargill city council
and is made up of people from our
community hopefully they're people who
have an interest in
local government and democracy their
role is to talk to people about how
we're represented in invercargill
the community panel's role is to be the
front line for the council
and finding out what the community would
like to see
with our representation this will
involve going out and talking to
different people in different groups in
the community
gathering that information together and
then writing a report
this information will then be used by
council to form their initial proposal
to apply to be on the invercargill city
council community panel
you can go to our website and follow the
links to the representation review email
your expression of interest and cv
and make sure you get it in by the 7th
of march
so invercargill how can we represent you
you